good afternoon thank you for coming
yesterday I gave a full account to the
prime minister of my actions between the
27th of March and the 14th of April what
I thought and did these asked me to
repeat that account directly to you I
know that millions of people in this
country have been suffering thousands
have died many are angry about what
they've seen of the media about my
actions I want to clear up the confusion
and misunderstandings that I can in
retrospect I should have made this
statement earlier it's many years since
I've said anything on television but I
will do my best to answer questions
after I've explained what happened I
also should clarify that I'm not here to
speak on behalf of the government or the
Prime Minister I'm explaining my own
actions and my own thinking the Prime
Minister was giving a press conference
later and he will answer questions
concerning government policy around
midnight on Thursday the 26th of March I
spoke to the prime minister he told me
that he tested positive for kovat we
discussed the national emergency
arrangements for number 10 given his
isolation and what I would do in number
10 the next day the next morning I went
to work as usual
I was in the succession of meetings
about this emergency I suddenly got a
call from my wife or was at home looking
after our 4 year old child she told me
she suddenly felt badly ill she'd
vomited and felt like she might pass out
and there would be nobody to look after
our child
none of our usual childcare options were
available they were alone in the house
after very briefly telling some
officials in number tear and what had
happened I immediately left the building
ran to a car and drove her this was
reported by the media at the time who
saw me run out of number 10 after a
couple of hours my wife felt a bit
better
there were many critical things at work
and she asked me to return in the
afternoon and I did that I that evening
I returned home and discussed the
situation with my wife she was ill she
might have Kove it though she did not
have a cough or a fever at this point
most of those who I work with most
closely including the prime minister
himself and others who sit within 50
defeat of me every day either had had
symptoms and had returned to work or
were absent with symptoms I thought
there was a distinct probability that I
had already caught the disease
I had a few conflicting thoughts in my
mind first I was worried that if my wife
and I were both seriously ill possibly
hospitalized there was nobody in London
that we could reasonably ask to look
after our child and exposed themselves
to kovat my wife had felt on the edge of
not being able to look after him safely
a few hours earlier I was thinking what
if the same or worse happens to me
there's nobody here that I can
reasonably ask to help the regulations
made clear I believe that risks to the
health of a small child were an
exceptional situation and I had a way of
dealing with this that minimized risk to
others second I thought that if I did
not develop symptoms that I might be
able to return to work to help deal with
the crisis there were ongoing
discussions about testing government
staff in order to keep people like me
working while of an isolating at this
point on the Friday advisers such as
myself had not been included in the list
of whom of who were tested but it was
possible that this might change the
following week therefore I thought that
after testing negative I could continue
working in fact this did not change in
special advisers were not tested and I
have never been tested third there have
been numerous full stories in the media
about my actions and statements
regarding Koval in particular there were
stories suggesting that I had opposed
lockdown and even that I did not care
about many deaths the years I have
warned of the dangers of pandemics last
year I wrote about the possible threat
of colloidal viruses and the urgent need
for planning the truth is that I'd
argued for lockdown I did not oppose it
but these stories have created a very
bad atmosphere around my hope I was
subject to threats of violence people
came to my house shouting threats there
were posts on social media encouraging
attacks there were many media reports on
TV showed pictures of my house I was
also worried - given the severity of
this emergency this situation would get
worse and I was worried about the
possibility of leaving my wife and child
at home
day and often into the night while I
worked in number tack I thought the best
thing to do with all the circumstances
was to drive to an isolated cottage on
my father's farm at this farm my parents
live in one house my sister and her two
children live in another house and there
was a separate cottage roughly 50 metres
away from either of them my tentative
conclusion on the Friday evening was
this if we are both unable to look after
our child then my sister or nieces can
look after him
my nieces are 17 and 20 they were old
enough to look after him but also young
enough to be in the safest category and
they had extremely kindly volunteered to
do so if needed but I thought if I do
not develop symptoms and as a testing
regime in place at work I could return
to work if I tested negative in that
situation I could leave my wife and
child behind in a safe place safe in the
form of support from family for shopping
in emergencies safe in the sense of
being away from our home which had
become a target and also safe for it for
everybody else because they were
completely isolated on a farm we could
not in fact anybody contrary to some
media reports there are no neighbors in
the normal sense of the word the nearest
of the home is a roughly half a mile
away so in this scenario I thought that
they could stay there for a few weeks I
could go back to work help colleagues
and everybody including the general
public would be safe I did not ask the
Prime Minister about this decision he
was ill himself and he had huge problems
to deal with every day I have to
exercise my judgement about things like
this and decide what to discuss with him
I thought that I would speak to him when
the situation clarified over coming days
including whether I had symptoms and
whether there were tests available
arguably this was a mistake and I
understand that some will say that I
should have spoken to the Prime Minister
before deciding what to do so I drove
the three of us up to Durham at night
arriving roughly at midnight I did not
stop on the way when I woke the next
morning Saturday the 28th of March I was
in pain and clearly had covered symptoms
including a bad headache and a serious
fever clearly I could not return to work
anytime soon for a day or two we were
both ill I was
bad my wife was ill but not enough that
she needed emergency help I got worse
she got better during the night of
Thursday a second of April my child woke
up he threw up and had a bad fever
he was very distressed we took medical
advice which was to call my my 9 an
ambulance was sent they assessed my
child that said he must go to hospital I
could barely stand up my wife fight with
him in the ambulance I stayed at home he
stayed the night in the hospital in the
morning my wife called to say that he
had recovered seen back to normal
doctors are tested in Fork Ovid and said
that they should return home there were
no taxis there were no taxis I drove to
the hospital picked him up then returned
home I do not leave the car or have any
contact with anybody at any point on
this short trip the hospitals I don't
know what roughly 5 miles or something
like two miles three miles form or
something like that a few days later the
hospital said that he tested negative
after I started to recover one day in
the second week I tried to walk outside
the house at one point the three of us
walked into woods owned by my father
next to the cottage that I was staying
in some people saw us in these woods
from a distance but we had no
interaction with them we had not left
the property we were on private land by
Saturday the 11th of April I was still
feeling weak and exhausted but other
than that I had no covert symptoms I
thought that I'd be able to return to
work the following week possibly
part-time it was obviously the situation
was extremely serious the Prime Minister
had been gravely ill colleagues were
dealing with huge problems and many were
ill or isolating I felt like I ought to
return to work if possible given I was
now recovering in order to relieve the
intense strain at number 10 on the
Saturday I sought that Saturday I sought
expert medical advice I explained our
family's symptoms and all the timings
and I asked if it was safe to return to
work on Monday Tuesday seek child care
and so on I was told that it was safe
and I could return to work and seek
child care
on Sunday the 12th of April 15 days
after hide first
after I've first displayed symptoms I
decided to return to work my wife was
very worried particularly given my
eyesight it seemed to seem to have been
affected by the disease she did not want
to risk a nearly 300 mile drive with our
child given how ill I had been we agreed
that we should go for a short drive to
see if I could drive safely we drove for
roughly half an hour and ended up on the
outskirts of our new castle town we did
not visit the castle we did not walk
around the town we parked by a river my
wife and I discussed the situation we
agreed that I could drive safely we
should turn around go her I felt a bit
sick we walked about 10 to 15 meters
from the car to the riverbank nearby we
sat there for about 15 minutes
we had no interactions with anybody I
felt better we returned to the car an
elderly gentleman walking nearby appear
to recognize me
my wife wished him happy used Easter
from a distance but we had no other
interaction we had at home on the way
home our child needed the toilet he was
in the backseat of the car we pulled
over to the side of the road my wife and
child
jumped out into the woods by the side of
the road they were briefly outside I
briefly joined them they played for a
little bit and then and then I got out
the car went outside we were briefly in
the woods we saw some people at a
distance but at no point do we break any
social distancing rules we then got back
in the car
and went home
we agreed that if I continue to improve
then the next day we should return to
London and I and I would go back to work
we returned to London on the evening of
Monday the 13th of April Easter Monday I
went back to work in number 10 the next
morning at no point between arriving and
leaving Darin did any of the three of us
and to my parents house or my sister's
house our only exchanges were shouted
conversations at a distance
my sister shop for us and left
everything outside in the last few days
there have been many media reports that
I returned to Durham after the 13th of
April all these stories are false there
is a particular report that I returned
there on the 19th of April photos and
data on my phone
prove this to be false and local CCTV if
it exists would also prove that I'm
telling the truth that I was in London
on that day I was not in Durham during
this two-week period my brothers my
mother's brother died with kovat there
are media reports that this had some
influence on my behavior these reports
false this private matter did not affect
my movements none of us saw him
none of us attended his funeral in this
very complex situation I tried to
exercise my judgment the best I could
I believe that in all the circumstances
I behave reasonably in Legally balancing
the safety of my family and the extreme
situation in number 10 and the public
interest in effective government to
which I could contribute I was involved
in decisions affecting millions of
people and I thought that I should try
to help as much as I could do I can
understand that some people will argue
that I should have stayed at my home in
London throughout I understand these
views I know the intense hardship and
sacrifice that the entire countries had
to go through however I respectfully
disagree the legal rules inevitably do
not cover all circumstances including
those that I found myself in I thought
and I think today that the rules
including those regarding small children
and extreme circumstances allowed me to
exercise my judgement about the
situation I found myself in including
the way that my London home have become
a target that all the complexity of the
situation I accept of course there is
room for reasonable disagree
without this I could also understand
some people think I should not have
driven at all anywhere but I taken
medical expert medical advice it was 15
days after symptoms I'd been told that I
could return to work and employ child
care I think it was reasonable and
sensible to make a short journey before
embarking on a five-hour drive to see
whether I was in a fit state to do this
the alternative was to stay in Durham
rather than going back to work and
contributing to the government's efforts
I believe I made the right judgment
though I can understand that others may
disagree with that
I've explained all the above to the
prime minister at some point during the
first week where we were both sick and
in bed I mentioned to him what I had
done
unsurprisingly given the condition we
were in neither of us remember the
conversation in any detail I do not I
did not make it my movements public at
the time because my London home was
already a target I did not believe that
I was obliged to make my parents and my
sister's home a target for harassment as
well I understand that means of people
see media coverage of this issue I know
that millions have injured awful
hardship including personal tragedies
over the past few months and people are
suffering every day and I know the
British people hate the idea of
unfairness I wants to explain what I
thought what I did and why over this
period because I think that people like
me who helped to make the rules should
be accountable for their actions